[Aplausos]
mi nombre es magdalena piñeiro pesos 110
kilos
soy gorda sino sabiendo cuento bien
escuchado
la verdad que durante mucho tiempo
mucho tiempo me costó poder decir mi
peso en público autodenominar muy gorda
me costó mucho porque esta sociedad
desde muy chiquita me dijo que yo debía
sentir vergüenza de mi cuerpo vergüenza
de mi peso
vergüenza de ser quien soy de ser gorda
esto responde a algo que hemos
denominado gordo fobia la discriminación
de las personas gordas por el hecho de
ser gordas
quizás a muchos muchos de ustedes les
suena un poco nueva la palabra es nueva
la palabra es nueva el término pero la
discriminación no
discriminación la llevamos sufriendo
años y años
guardo fobia como les decía la
discriminación que sufrimos las personas
gordas por el hecho de ser gordas es
algo extensible creo que prácticamente
toda la sociedad porque al final todo el
mundo tiene miedo a engordar verdad
imagínense el susto que más de una una
se llevaría se hundía en el reflejo del
espejo apareciera un cuerpo como el mío
si esta sociedad está obsesionada con
ser delgada que es la otra cara del
espejo de no ser gordos o gordas son dos
caras del mismo espejo lo mismo que el
rechazo a labor dura el rechazo a las
personas que encarnamos esa gordura las
personas gordas
vagas perezosas descontroladas
sedentarias opulentas egoístas son
algunos de los términos que se hacen con
los que se hace referencia a nuestro
cuerpo según el estudio del discurso
popular sobre la obesidad de la
universidad de almería
por qué sucede esto bueno eso
necesitaría mucho más tiempo que el que
tengo hoy para poder explicarles y
compartirles pero lo que sí me dispongo
a compartirles hoy son tres claves tres
frases que nos dicen constantemente a
las personas gordas en esta sociedad
gordo fóbica que refuerzan esa
discriminación tres frases
está mal ser tú
aquí no cabes reduce tu tamaño está mal
ser tú aquí no cabes reduce tu tamaño
y para que quede más claro les voy a dar
un ejemplo y voy a empezar con mi
principio mi mamá embarazada
mi mamá cuando se quedó embarazada era
una persona super delgada que fue
guardando muchísimo durante el embarazo
y todo el mundo le decía ay
qué pena que gorda te has puesto con lo
guapa que eras
porque está mal ser tú
mi mamá le costó él empezó a costar cada
vez más caber en el transporte público
aquino cada vez
y empezaba a ir al ginecólogo y al final
del embarazo aunque no había ningún
problema en el embarazo nunca lo tuvo el
ginecólogo decidió poner la dieta porque
no podía estar tan gorda
reduce tu tamaño
está mal ser tú aquí no cabe reduce tu
tamaño se entienden las cosas que me
aman hizo caso al ginecólogo y parece
que yo me adelgace en la panza ahí donde
hice mi primer dieta imagínense
tengo un récord seguro
entonces nací como que toda jugadita
dicen que porque me adelgace en la panza
yo no sé la causa pero nací toda
jugadita y la cuestión es que fue una
bebé gorda igualmente y fui una niña
gorda también y saben que se le dice a
las niñas gordas porque está mal ser tú
aquino cada vez reduce tu tamaño
las niñas gordas y los niños gordos
crecemos con comentarios sobre nuestros
cuerpos
nos dicen que nuestros cuerpos son feos
que nuestros cuerpos están mal que
nuestros cuerpos deben modificarse nos
educan en el control en la restricción
en el miedo a la vergüenza todo porque
tienen miedo de que de adultos o adulta
seamos gordos gordas alerta spoilers lo
somos
hay gente que quiera adelgazar o nunca
nunca porque saben que tanto la gordura
como la delgadez son multifactoriales es
decir hay muchos motivos por los que una
persona puede ser gorda o delgada y no
todo el mundo puede ni quiere cambiar su
cuerpo
los niños y las niñas como les decía
crecemos con miedo con miedo muy metido
dentro del cuerpo al punto de que a
veces dejamos de jugar ya no queremos ir
a las plazas no queremos ir a los
parques porque si no cabemos en los
columpios yo recuerdo nunca empezar a no
caber en los columpios y también
recuerdo tener miedo a quedarme atascada
en el tobogán quizás no sucediera pero
yo tenía miedo o sea el miedo estaba muy
adentro de mí
y así empezamos a ir al colegio y en el
colegio nos encontramos con bullying o
acoso escolar
y nos encontramos con la palabra que
define nuestro cuerpo utilizada como
insulto gordo gordas nos gritan y
avergonzados agachamos la cabeza
a misa no me pasa me costó persona me
pasaje mirar ahora y yo sí que pasó
decirme
cuando bien mi gordita ni rece ni tan
ancha de huesos o soy gorda
gorda no es un insulto solo podría ser
un insulto si consideramos que serlo lo
eres si yo no considero que ser gordo
gorda hace un insulto lo que sí me
parece insultante que nos digan a las
personas gordas constantemente que
hagamos deporte como si no lo hiciéramos
nunca
y que además cuando lo hacemos nos hagan
comentarios gordo fóbicos sobre nuestro
cuerpo porque ellos saben está mal ser
tú aunque luego no quepamos en algunos
espacios deportivos o aparatos de
gimnasio porque ya sabes aquí no cabes o
que no sea ropa deportiva para nosotras
porque reduce tu tamaño
pero no solo pasa además con la ropa
deportiva y pasa con todo con todo
chaquetas no sé pantalones abrigos botas
de todo yo no sé la cantidad de veces
que entre una tienda y me encontré con
una dependienta que me mira de arriba
abajo así nace un escáner aquí no hay
ropa para ti
a veces con unos tonos de expresión que
me dan ganas de revolver toda la tienda
no devengan ser serios que de hecho yo
además siempre teniendo que vayamos
desnudas las gordas por la calle
o sea
voy a confesar que a mí en verano no me
importaría pero en invierno tengo frío
necesito necesito un abrigo
definitivamente de todas formas debo
confesar que no todas las personas
gordas creo que seríamos capaces de
andar por ahí desnudas a la calle otra
cosa que nos dice la sociedad gordo
fóbicas que debemos esconder nuestro
cuerpo es que nadie lo muestra no dónde
está el cuerpo gordo
en los productos culturales
prácticamente no aparecemos y cuando
aparecemos o aparecemos a aquella manera
la verdad yo nunca vi a una persona
gorda el protagonista de una serie una
película exitosa digna de amor libre
feliz
si nos ve como los glotones de echarle
la fábrica de chocolate
si nos ve como las crueles y malvadas
hermanastras de la cenicienta shinobi
como la mala malísima familia de harry
potter si nos vi como el peor futuro
posible de la humanidad en world
ahí sí
no la representación o mala
representación somos las hiper visibles
invisibles esas son más las personas
gordas y que por no tener no tenemos ni
hemos is en el teléfono pero no cuenta
con el poco de me di cuenta hay personas
de distintos
trabajos de distinto corte de pelo no
distintos géneros
distintos empleos ropa con lo hay de
todo un poco pero ni una persona gorda
ni una eso sí hay dinosaurios halladas
sirenas aliens pero parece que poner una
persona abordar a echarlo y mucha
imaginación
y ahí se quedó
lo peor de todo es que hace muy poco que
me di cuenta de esto muy poco tiempo
estoy tan acostumbrada a ser invisible
que a veces no soy consciente de mi
propia invisibilidad a veces me siento
un cuerpo en suspensión esperando algún
día acaben anulado
porque la verdad es que para caber
además voy a tener que modificar mi
cuerpo porque esta sociedad me dejó muy
claro muy claro que no se va adaptar a
mí que el mundo no se adaptará a mí que
yo me tengo que adaptar al mundo así que
no cabemos
no cabemos no quedemos en algunas sillas
de teatros de cines de restaurantes no
cabemos en algunos transportes públicos
aviones autobuses en algunos trenes no
cabemos en algunos asientos de sillas de
peluquería por ejemplo en algunos coches
y si quieren hacer las parques de
atracciones con lo que a mí me gusta una
montaña rusa
no cabemos no cabemos en las playas así
no se crean que no soy consciente de que
hay playas kilométricas donde podría
caber perfectamente mi cuerpo lo que me
refiero es que siempre nos dicen que
nuestros cuerpos no son de placer que
nuestros cuerpos no son de bikini que es
otra manera bastante elegante de
decirnos que no cabemos
no queremos tanto en las relaciones sexo
afectivas ni en las relaciones amorosas
yo no sé la cantidad de veces que le
golpeé la puerta al amor y el amor me
respondió está mal ser tú aquí no cabe
reduce tu tamaño
y yo yo boluda que esperaba que el amor
me cantará a mí por un beso de la gorda
ayudaría lo que fuera
no no paso
no pasaría de más se hubiera pasado le
hubiera acusado de apología de la
obesidad
porque eso es lo que dicen cuando una
persona demuestra amor por una persona
gorda o una gorda muestra amor por sí
misma apología de la obesidad eso me
dicen a mí también cuando subo mis
propias fotos a las redes sociales
apología de la obesidad me pregunto si a
un calvo que sube sus propias fotos a
sus redes sociales dicen que es apología
de la calvicie oa una persona mayor que
hace apología de la vejez
ahí lo dejo
parece increíble de todas formas la
palma de la gordo fobia se la lleva en
el sector empresarial y el sector
sanitario está gente de la que dependen
nuestros recursos
nada más y nada menos nuestra inclusión
social nuestra salud física y nuestra
salud mental nuestra supervivencia vamos
pasábamos las burdas al sector
empresarial buscando un empleo y nos
dicen cosas como
no eres lo que estamos buscando
no vas con el perfil no contratamos
gente así aquí
no en esta empresa no contratamos a
personas gordas su historia esto está
basado en hechos reales
según benítez amasar es de la
universidad de málaga o moreno pestaña
de la universidad de granada el peso
puede ser determinante a la hora de
conseguir empleo sobre todo si eres una
mujer gorda
muy fuerte y sea el sector sanitario
bueno que voy a decir espero que no seas
una gorda que tenga que ir al médico por
una gripe porque vas a salir con una
dieta de adelgazamiento de ahí porque ya
sabemos que las personas gordas hasta la
gripe es culpa de la grasa
todo es culpa de la grasa todo lo que le
pasa es a la gorda es culpa de la grasa
son nos dicen siempre porque porque nos
atienden desde unos prejuicios en torno
a lo que supuestamente comemos en torno
al ejercicio que supuestamente no
hacemos en torno a la fuerza de voluntad
que supuestamente no tenemos y ahí está
se prioriza además siempre siempre
nuestro adelgazamiento por encima de
cualquier dolencia da igual lo que te
pase lo importante es que bajes de peso
y para que vean lo duro que puede llegar
a hacer esto les cuento el caso de
amanda lee un adicto care gorda que a
principios de este año subió a sus redes
sociales un caso que la verdad que
estremece
esa contó que fue el médico porque tenía
unos dolores digestivos que no le
permitían comer y cuando el médico a la
vez le dice bueno no comer en ti no es
un problema
haciendo alusión a que hacía lo mejor
adelgazar y a una persona gorda para que
sea alimentar a una persona gorda no
resulta que se insistió insistió y le
terminaron diagnosticando cáncer de
colon
imagina imagínense la cantidad de
personas porque esa insistió de pero la
cantidad de gente que no existe la
cantidad de personas que desisten frente
a la autoridad médica
imagínense las consecuencias
y además esa cuando compartes esta
historia suya en sus redes sociales se
da cuenta que no es la única que hay
muchísima gente diciéndole que le pasa
lo mismo
y es cierto a la persona sorda nos pasa
que haya otras que se alegren de nuestra
enfermedad a verse adelgazamos
y más triste aún nos pasa a nosotras
mismas
que nos alegremos a ver si adelgazamos o
no estamos enfermas esto es gordo fobia
esto es la gordo fobia que nos lleva así
de la manito del canon corporal de la
delgadez hacia el mayor desprecio que
podemos tener por nosotros y nosotras
mismas
qué es preferir estar enfermas o muertas
antes que seguir siendo gordas en esta
sociedad gordo fábrica
y saben que es lo más fuerte de todo
que cuando se le pregunta a la sociedad
sociedad por qué
porque nos haces esto porque nos
invisibiliza en la cultura en los medios
de comunicación porque no nos dejan
vivir una infancia libre porque nos
discriminan en el trabajo en el teatro
en el cine en la consulta médica en la
calle en la escuela en todas partes
porque no dejas de decirnos todo el rato
está mal ser tú aquí no cabe reduce tu
tamaño hasta marchar tú aquí no cabes
reduce tu tamaño porque nos trata de una
forma tan cruel
la sociedad me responde
es que me preocupa tu salud
permítanme que discrepe aquí no hay
nadie preocupado por la salud de la
gente gorda
el bullying escolar no es bueno para la
salud la exclusión social y laboral no
es buena para la salud las negligencias
médicas no son buenas para la salud y el
estrés y el acoso ni los insultos
nada de esto es un síntoma de buena
salud la ansiedad la depresión la
agorafobia los trastornos de conducta
alimentaria provocados por la gordo
fobia no son un síntoma de buena salud y
tampoco es un síntoma de buena salud que
haya gente que atente contra su propia
salud y mutile su cuerpo intentando
alcanzar ese canon de la delgadez o que
muchas personas gordas prefiramos estar
muertas e incluso enfermas y pasarlo
fatal
antes que seguir habitando este cuerpo
la gordo fobia es mala para la salud la
bordó fobia mata
así que a toda esa gente que está
realmente preocupada por nuestra salud
son lo que les vengo a pedir es que por
favor empiecen por dejar de
discriminarnos eso es el primer acto de
salud que se puede hacer hacia las
personas gordas tratamos con amor con
respeto y dejar de decir está mal ser tú
aquí no cabes reduce tu tamaño así que
muchos y muchas de ustedes ahora mismo
se estarán mirando un poco en su espejo
interior y pensando que yo fui gordo
fuego que sabes y sophie gordo fob
aquella vez no se sientan culpables por
favor esto no es culpa de nadie no es
culpa de ustedes esto es una
discriminación estructural que hemos
heredado de mucho mucho atrás ustedes no
tienen la culpa pero si tienen una
responsabilidad
y es la de frenar esto
porque yo puedo plantar me acabo y ante
ustedes
y explicar qué es la guardo fobia cómo
podemos identificarla pero yo no puedo
explicar el dolor que produce la gordo
fobia el dolor de ser vulnerada
humillada invisibilizada violentada
constantemente 24 horas al día 7 días a
la semana en todos los espacios sociales
durante toda mi vida
y ver mi cuerpo como símbolo de lo que
todo el mundo teme hacer mi cuerpo como
símbolo de todo lo que está mal en el
mundo mi cuerpo definido como el peor
error de la humanidad
el peor error de la humanidad
saben qué
no lo soy no lo somos las personas
gordas no somos uno de los peores
errores de la humanidad la gordo fobia
lo es muchas gracias
[Aplausos]